all right let's get back to the good
stuff
[Music]
so it's Sunday which means Doctor Who
and it's time for me to review a classic
Doctor Who story and I've had more than
a few people tell me that I am that I
just don't like classic or that I don't
get it and like in my defense a lot of
the stuff that I've been covering lately
I did not like a fair amount and I think
I owed it not only do you folks but to
myself to do a classic story that I knew
I liked now my patreon supporters still
voted on this but I stacked the deck I
only gave them options that were stories
that I know I really like and much to my
joy they picked my favorite classic era
story that I've seen so far possibly my
favorite Doctor Who story of all time
and that is the Tom Baker era story city
of death now before I get into the
episode itself I'll tell you this first
long before I was a Doctor Who fan I was
a Douglas Adams fan I love the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy so much
I have and not only do I have a copy
that is the first four books in one
volume it's leather-bound I I loved
Douglas Adams so much now Douglas Adams
was the script editor on this and his
contribution to this particular story
the official credit for the writing is
David Agnew but that's a pseudonym so
the original treatment was done by David
Fisher but he wasn't available to do the
revisions and the rewrites so those were
done by Graham Williams who was the
showrunner of the time
and Douglas Adams who was the script
editor at the time and exactly how much
of the thing overall is is Adams as work
it's hard to say the general premise
seems to have come from Fisher's
original treatment and script but
Douglass's Adams his Douglas Adams is
boy trying to say that name as a
possessive that's that's tricky Douglas
Adams is fingerprints are all over this
and I love it so much like I I could
seriously review this story by just
sitting here and quoting you my favorite
lines from this from this story they are
so numerous and Tom Baker delivers them
so expertly he knows when to be dry he
knows when to be cutting and and the
other characters get some great lines as
well it has one of my favorite
descriptions of the doctor particularly
Tom Baker's doctor where you have some
of the villains and one of them goes I
don't think he's as stupid as he seems
and the other one goes my dear no one
could be as stupid as he seems like I oh
god I love all this okay let's talk
synopsis and premise so this story kicks
off initially we get a flashback - a
flashback I mean way back and we don't
get full context for it's a little bit
later but it's most of it is set in
Paris and we have the doctor and Ramona
Ramona - Lal award on traveling through
Paris and they happen to feel like a
weird time thing if Ike was that well
there's a count who is you know paying
but also kind of forcing the scientists
to work on experiments that are causing
some weird stuff with time going on and
at the same time there's also a plot to
steal the Mona Lisa that the doctor gets
all wrapped up in and it's all tied to
this
the count who's our primary villain
played by Julian Glover now folks these
days would know him as rain maester
pycelle from Game of Thrones I I always
think of him first and foremost as
Donovan from the third Indiana Jones
film Last Crusade but he he is the count
in this and he's really good he's I mean
Julian Glover is a good actor anyway but
he is he is charming when he needs to be
he is he is gruff and intimidating when
he needs to be he has a sense of
presence that helps he's good at selling
what is at times some pretty ridiculous
lines and things that his character has
to go through and all that works really
well the dr. Romana also managed to pick
up this sort of detective who is you
know tracking down some some weird stuff
that's going on and he is such he's a
bull in the china shop certainly
compared to the doctor because his this
guy solution to everything is to punch
it or break it or knock it out if it's a
person and like to them to the point
that to open a wine bottle he doesn't
even bother the core he just breaks the
end off of the wine bottle and and does
see a like his way of dealing with
things clash with the doctors and then
the few times that they actually kind of
like are able to work together decently
that's great that's wonderful stuff and
there is just a really well sort of
paced progression to the whole story and
I actually think this has some of the
best cliffhangers of classic who and
that might sound weird because most of
them are not they're not designed around
a perilous situation is what people
usually think of as a cliffhanger and
that's usually how I made it to but for
the episode breaks like the first one is
just the reveal of the alien now this is
an alien
we actually saw earlier in the story but
we didn't know that it was connected to
the character that it is so it's it's
not um oh my god how are they going to
get out of this which is a cliffhanger
almost never works for me because I know
they're gonna get out of it but this was
more of a oh so there's a wrinkle to
this story hmm and then you know later
on we sees you know cuz the doctor jumps
around time a few points and we see
somebody in the past who really
shouldn't be there and that's your
cliffhanger that's a really good cuz
again it's like oh I can't wait to see
this explained as opposed to yeah yeah
we know they're not really gonna die
which you know that's my feeling about
most cliffhangers but I really I really
like these ones cuz they leave you
intrigued and wanting to see how does
that fit together which again feels
Douglas Adams asked his his stories for
Doctor Who and in general always have an
interesting way that everything fits
together as you get new wrinkles and new
pieces of information that like feel
weird and you kind of just want to see
what the explanation is and sometimes
it's it's you know cool and neat and
twisty and sometimes it's just funny and
there's just and there's a really fun
layering of things because you've got
this stuff going on with time
displacement and you've got an alien but
at the same time you've just got a art
heist and these things should be
clashing but they really don't if there
was one criticism I were to make it's an
asterisk criticism but I do feel it's
worth it now and it didn't really bother
me but I do feel it's worth
acknowledging that the the I said it's
set in Paris and they did actually go
and shoot on location in Paris and you
can tell because there are a number of
sequences that are extended longer than
they need to be of the doctor and Romana
outside in external locations around
Paris and you know I I appreciate the
the show wanted to show off the location
they I think they overdo it a little bit
they ever do a little
frontend and there's like a couple of
like when the dark especially in the
first episode or so with the doctor
muramana will go for one location to
another rather than just have them show
up where we know they already know how
to get to we have to show them walking
through the streets of Paris again so
that we can have more footage of them
walking through the streets of Paris and
it's the sort it's the sort of thing
that normal narrative you know
progression of editing you wouldn't be
showing this or you wouldn't be showing
it for as long as stretch as they are so
that's sort of showing off hey where it
is just a little overdone at the very
least though if I were to compare it to
say the two doctors were a lot of people
pointed out that it was of what I
complained about the budgetary
restrictions on that one they pointed
out that it was shot on location in
Spain a big part of why I didn't care
that it was shot in location in Spain
for that story was that there was no
reason for that story to be taking place
in Spain it was a completely arbitrary
setting nothing about the primary story
being told had anything to do with that
locale whereas the city of death setting
it in Paris is actually relevant because
there are plot points involving the
Louvre and the Mona Lisa which is in
Paris so you know it's actually it
actually impacts the story that it's set
in Spain whereas two doctors it was
completely arbitrary which made me hate
that resource allocation went to them
shooting on location in Spain for no
good reason so even though y'all I
complain about it just a tiny bit like
iíve seen location shoot and go way
worse so Wow I'll take it I'll be happy
but ultimately what I love about this is
primarily just the dialogue I and and I
think that's probably where Douglas
Adams had the most influence was the
dialogue and the lines because they are
just so funny I owe the doctor you know
talking to the countess and oh well your
beautiful woman probably and just its
little dust off lines like that that
everywhere what a lovely Butler he's so
violent yes I
Oh like I could seriously I could spend
the next 10 minutes just rattling off
some of the best lines from this and
from this episode and that is is
probably more than anything a big part
of what puts it over the top because
there's a lot to like you it's it's a
pretty tight story all things considered
as it gets towards the end and it gets
into where it's going and how things pan
out and progress and I'll I guess I'll
talk a little bit about spoilers and the
very end I mean I just love this thing
so obviously you've got that so if
you're worried about spoilers this is
probably the point to bow out so if
you're still here in terms of the
realisation that the count and and his
species and their attempts to leave
earth 400 million years ago was actually
what kicked off life that's the sort of
thing that normally I'd be like I don't
know about that but they they give it
proper weight with the doctor point out
that like look your race died so that a
planet could gain new life I'm sorry
that's what happened but dude this is
just the deal and I kind of feel like
there was appropriate weight given to
that and it wasn't it wasn't tossed off
as haphazardly as these sorts of
revelations often are and I think that
that makes it go down better whereas
historically that sort of thing is
something that I don't usually care too
much for so and just seeing you know the
different time displaced versions of
julian glover and the man the mask i
find this very funny and i don't know
why i find this funny here whereas other
times the the alien effects stuff can
can pull me out of it but for some
reason it works for me here I kind of
love the fact that the aliens head
because it's a mask you know worn by I
don't know if they actually put Julian
Glover in that it's a completely head
for a mask that could have used a
stand-in but in any case whoever they
put it on its you know covering their
head so obviously the alien
ed is bigger than a human head and yet
were meant to believe that that is fully
encased within a human mask to create a
normal-sized head and when you know they
like pull it pull the human mask off and
there's the head like that's so much
bigger than the head you just removed
how does that work and that should pull
me up but it does and I find it kind of
adorable and there's just this this
story's just joy to me it's the the ease
and the flow and the chemistry and the
dialogue between you know Tom Baker and
basically everybody he episodes like
this are a big part of why he's my
favorite doctor he's not always in my
favorite stories he doesn't always have
my favorite companions but he I see
episodes like this and see his delivery
in them and I'm like oh I love this guy
god I could I could watch this guy
forever and it's it's just it warms my
heart this this story and I was I was
really glad to be able to to see it and
be or my oh yes classic who can not only
be good it can be great
so that city of death my to date
favorite classic era Doctor Who story
and after having had to slog through
some iffy classic whose stuff lately it
was nice to talk about so that'll wrap
it up for me have you seen city of Death
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff to do such as
like and subscribe and you know what it
is you don't need me to tell you there's
buttons and there's links and there's a
patreon there's stuff down below hey you
want to vote on the next classic whose
story that I'm gonna do the patreon is
the way to get in on that in any case
just remember folks you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]